so I just heard her to post this last
little bit of clips that I shot while I
was on the set of the law and order SVU
show it was such a great experience I
had so much fun I met so many awesome
people and I love that I can share all
of it with you guys so let me know what
you think of the clips let me know if
you watch the show and kids it's kind of
a pg-13 show so if you're watching it
your mom yells at you or dad um hey
don't mention my name because then I'm
gonna get in the emails it's definitely
a different role than my fun crazy
videos that I make here on YouTube so
for me it was really fun to try to play
another character because the only other
character that I really ever play is me
just you you know what happened the last
time I go go trick or treat yeah that's
right I didn't do it yeah I look forward
to seeing what you guys think all right
bye thanks so much for watching I love
you I think I kind of stole that from
Shane Dawson sorry Shane some hair and
makeup and I'm going to die right now
this is gonna be my dead leg I was
talking to my camera sorry this is my
strangled neck this is my Dead face my
dad legs
hey in his first movie la sketchy
check out my stitches nervous we said
stitches I was like you know what I dead
here in bed um I had a good life but
yeah no pulse no purse I'm all bloodied
up this is my bedroom
dude there's my toes
oh man this is my hotel room pretty
awesome
this is Victor he has a fun little card
and I upcoming SVU episode what's your
to hear things Richard and I got
allergies hello Luis is what Becca did
and make up all kinds of yo Z colors and
put in some latex and I'm a bloody mess
how long did it take for this merci
thank you two minutes you're the more
inches my last day on set and right now
there's fabulous teams in here eli
beerus what's with the trail we look
like two werewolf oh hi I was just
taking a little nap here I'm sitting
here in the car I got Michael up here in
the front he is driving me to set are
you excited right now
very excited be so excited had your kids
I Mike and Joe just wanted to say hi
beagle boys love you guys better be good
no sex um they're shooting intrapartum
really save the ball hearts turn
surprise for you I'm gonna go visit the
graphics people so now what's your
what's your role here I'm a graphic
artist you're all types of things like
graphic signage anything you see on a
computer that one's kind of badass
hey what's up don't mess with me at once
hello once I go and make it look 16 but
I mean that's okay did you make the
iPhone animation yeah so in the scene I
actually have to click I'm typing on my
phone that's what you're not really
typing it's look at this now how did you
do that because I am extremely curious
I'm actually working on that right now
oh you did some keynote you got put in
the hole typing animation it's kind of a
pain to dinner but we've made it work
for us I'm making mocha dicks
coffee labels this is just if not and
what is mocha Dex is that is the coffee
shop that is in York's version
illustrator using this is cs4 oh nice
I'm still rocking cs3 don't tell me I
won't tell okay that's the hotel stay
what they asked out hotel nice
so some of these out they all get made
yeah well I make Mitchell that makes a
cup that is so great final illustration
illustrator right here mocha dick
pretty awesome the coffee shop here
here's the wonderful logo
graphic team did a good job some of you
guys might know there's a lot of time
spent doing nothing between takes so
what do you do you know pass the time
while this is what I play farmville I'm
going to harvest some of my strawberries
they are fully grown hanging out here
being a dead body on the table along
this Creek side right now and good
removal their removal it's real
complicated my mom hey mommy mm-hmm
those are my skin guys Wednesday 9:00
p.m. NBC watch SVU
hmm